voilà donc pour cette prise de parole du
chancelier allemand Olaf shoes devant le
Bundestag Olaf Scholtz qui l'affirme il
ne peut pas être permis que les
frontières soient déplacées par la force
sur le continent européen c'est une
bonne chose dit-il que nous soutenions
l'Ukraine avec des armes il parle
d'ailleurs de rupture mot employé à
plusieurs reprises l'Allemagne sera
toujours devant dans le soutien
militaire à l'Ukraine en face sur la
livraison des chars de bataille tiplés
ou par deux elle est évidemment
confirmée c'est le fruit dit-il de
concertation avec nos partenaires
européens et c'est une décision juste
Karim on a donc davantage de détails sur
cette ce feu vert allemand donnait donc
aujourd'hui à la livraison de chars de
combat léopardeux
ce n'est pas une façon de d'avoir cédé à
la pression pour lui ça a été concerté
c'est une décision qui a été longuement
pesée c'est pour ça que ça a pris
beaucoup de temps en préambule il a
évoqué une guerre je cite impérialiste
épouvantable qui menace la sécurité et
pas seulement celle de de l'Ukraine que
les frontières ont été déplacées alors
il a évoqué ce de ce changement en
quelque sorte de de trajectoire de
l'histoire mais ça il l'avait en quelque
sorte déjà fait au moment du
déclenchement de la guerre le 27 février
dernier l'Allemagne avait annoncé
qu'elle allait livrer des armes à
l'Ukraine alors ce n'était pas des armes
lourdes ce n'était pas des chars mais
c'était déjà une forme de de rupture
avec une forme de de pacifisme
institutionnalisé qui était en vigueur
quasiment depuis la Deuxième Guerre
mondiale donc on continue dans cette
dans cette logique de rupture on
continue à faire tomber un certain
nombre de de ce qui apparaissait être
des des lignes rouges mais Olaf Scholl
ça aussi tenu à rassurer une partie de
l'opinion une partie de la population
qui s'inquiète qu'avec cette livraison
d'armes lourdes et bien dans une logique
d'escalade plus importante il a
clairement voulu montrer que on était
dans une logique de quête de d'équilibre
entre une posture où on veut aider
l'Ukraine tout en tentant de laisser
encore la chance à la paix tout en
tentant de garder un point d'équilibre
mais évidemment cette cette décision de
livrer des léopards 2 et est historique
et marque une rupture de plus il y en a
déjà eu beaucoup depuis le déclenchement
de ce conflit alors vous l'avez dit il
affirme que cette ce feu vert du jour et
le résultat d'une concertation
disons assez longue avec les partenaires
européens en tout cas la pression était
considérable sur Olaf Scholt son témoin
d'ailleurs les multiples réactions à
présent de la France de la Pologne ou
encore du Royaume-Uni qui salue cette
immédiatement cette cette décision c'est
vrai que très rapidement il y a eu des
réactions notamment celle de la Pologne
qui peut être le pays qui a fait le plus
pression sur sur l'al un grand pas vers
l'objectif d'arrêter la Russie ce sont
les mots du Premier ministre polonais du
côté des Britanniques on s'en est
félicité puisque les Léopards 2 seront
aux côtés des challengers des
challengers 2 d'ailleurs
que l'Allemagne et la Grande-Bretagne
étaient les deux pays qui étaient en
première ligne pour pour aider du crâne
militairement en termes de matériel mais
pas seulement alors c'est vrai qu'il y a
eu beaucoup de concertation mais c'est
vrai aussi qu'il y a eu énormément de
pression sur les épaules de la Schulz à
l'intérieur de l'espace politique
allemand d'abord puisque les écologistes
les socialistes ont poussé notamment le
ministre de la Défense pour que
rapidement soit formé des temps kystes
Ukrainiens pour que rapidement soit
livré ses chars et puis évidemment il y
a eu la pression des pays partenaires on
peut encore une fois citer la Pologne
mais clairement la chose ne voulait pas
apparaître comme l'homme qui a cédé à la
pression mais comme l'homme qui a pris
le temps de la réflexion et du peu de le
pour et le contre dans une logique où la
désescalade n'est jamais à mettre de
côté il a d'ailleurs souligné que rien
n'était mathématique et qu'il n'y avait
pas de bonne ou de mauvaises décisions
mais en tout cas des décisions mûrement
réfléchies merci